- [Narrator] This is S.J. -
a prehensile tailed skink.
Found in the Solomon Islands,
this little guy is the
largest known of its kind.
The prehensile-tailed skink's
body is a greenish olive color
with scattered black scales.
This coloring, combined
with its slow movements,
helps the skink to camouflage
with its surroundings
and hide from enemies.
Like other skinks, its head
is flat and triangular.
Their strong legs and sharp
claws help them to climb trees.
The defining feature on this
skink is its prehensile tail,
which allows them to grasp
objects and branches for balance.
Their tail makes up nearly
half of their bodies length.
The prehensile-tailed skink's
habitat is under threat
due to deforestation for
lumber and agriculture.
This and the skink's
popularity within the pet trade
has threatened their survival in the wild.
This is the prehensile-tailed skink.